waving flags and chanting slogans for
the third year protesters in hartoum
took to the streets to remember victims
of a brutal crackdown by security forces
to break up a pro-democracy sitting at
the army headquarters i want to see
fair trails
for all those who involved
the killers are known
not as
individual soldiers but including those
who planned
for this massacre
and those who ordered
for it
there were similar protests in other
cities the 2019 sit-in led to the ouster
of president omar al-bashir after 30
years in power but it continued as
demonstrators demanded a civilian
government
witnesses and survivors have accused the
security forces of using excessive force
to disperse protesters there were
reports of bodies being thrown into the
nile river and allegations of sexual
violence a transitional government sworn
in three months after the attack
promised to investigate the attack that
government was deposed last year
since the military took power in october
hopes have faded that justice will be
served anytime soon the committee set up
to investigate the attack was suspended
and nearly eight months on there's been
no talk of reviving it
amira caboose lost her 26 year old son
in the sit-in she says despite the
delays she continues to demand for those
responsible for his death to be held
accountable
there was a postponement in the issue of
justice for the protester killed and
people would say let's focus on moving
forward and the issue of justice would
come later this is something we will not
accept ever again the delay has led to
more lives lost in protests
the u.n mission in sudan along with the
african union and the regional body igad
are facilitating talks to end sudan's
political crisis resulting from the
military takeover it's due to launch
talks between the various sides next
week we are quite sure
that justice
for the victims
a victim-centered perspective of justice
and transitional justice
as protesters continue to call for
justice they're also asking for the
military to hand over power to a
civilian government nearly 100 people
have been killed in anti-military
demonstrations and the calls for
accountability are growing louder but
achieving it still remains far from
reach heber morgan al-jazeera horton